[Music]
i'm making potato grating
marzar's doing meatballs looking nice
could be rounder got the meatballs
got the wife
i got the dough
got the food
what happened here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
glad to meet someone we made flower
crowns
looking good guys thank you
damn what a savage wear it
so much i got to do it
i'm waiting
yeah just take one out
oh my god that scared me
when you took the ice out it looked over
at me and i was like
oh i hate that
[Music]
it is really creepy
yes
okay yeah changing it nicely that looks
nice
[Laughter]
it's like what did you say about me
that's what i thought
okay i went with green melon did you
just do that well it melts you can put
as much as you want
you're gonna try the melon
that's actually
look at that it tastes like eyes
[Music]
we're doing a little extern excursion
it's very humid
someone say hot
let's go
it's the first time
that i see him or her you didn't realize
like i asked four times do you see it
you said yes look at that
oh we can go down to the water
amazing
it's been really windy lately so i think
that cleared out everything whoa people
are swimming those buildings are usually
quite hazy
but now they're super clear
it's so pretty
so refreshing from it being what some
would say is hot 36 degrees and very
humid
mine
[Music]
um
[Music]
again
you point at which one you want
okay
you want this one
would you say that you are a
happy dog
here's your order
we decided to go back
whoa
because it's so hot and then we can make
the buggy swim
instead
i mean it's not hot they think it's hot
god i did leg day today i'm gonna die
tomorrow i feel it here we go miami
is that a snake
hey guy you need me to help you down
[Music]
yes return
you've grown since i last seen you
i doubt it's the same one but who knows
dude you're gonna have a lot of climbing
to do ahead of you i just schooled this
kid one more let's go
oh that was embarrassing muffin man i
hope you're watching this vlog
good game
i think i got this game if i can keep my
valkyrie it's a it's a win
okay
does he have another one
all right he knows what to get rid of i
think he wants to get me killed he's not
gonna go for it
yes
this is a weird game
he's gonna
okay haste as long as i can tank this
i'm i win
yeah there we go
sorry japanese kiddos yeah boy is back
on mythic let's go okay i'm done now
we're filling up our little pool
it's gonna be nice
hell yeah bow and get your
kind of
your japanese pug now okay
no
wow
some would
say
it's high
but me
[Music]
i'll see you reminds me
it was marci's idea to get this kid pool
and at first i was like
no but here i am
and it's really nice
[Music]
[Music]
we're at the beach thank you's going for
that
it's so lovely here
here we go again
oh you love it
just bloody happen
the water's so nice
oh she's so cute
my essay is out playing
with their friends i'm chilling with my
girl
oh yeah
looking sexy
this is such an instagram tent that we
got
you're supposed to be able to see a
mount fuji but it's a bit hazy but you
can kind of see this silhouette and
there's another one
pretty cool
there's the girls
everyone
chilling at the beach
but you wish you were here but you're
not
too bad
they like it that way maya's having the
best time
all right aki can you explain the rules
again okay so this is suikawari which is
like you take a watermelon you're
blindfolded and then you get a stick
and everyone else has to tell you where
to go
i'm finally living the anime life
do you want to hit her oh thank you yes
that would be an honor
that's my weapon of choice
okay
it's destroyed
the girls are going on a walk
there's a
shrine over there
[Music]
this hair man such a lovely day amazing
i haven't had a day like this forever
love it i think surfing on a beach like
this in front of mount fuji would be a
dream come true
[Music]
damn you can totally see my fuji now
[Music]
where'd it go
there it is
[Music]
okay
it makes sense now
yep
it feels like 42 yeah if you're weak i
don't even feel like feels like winter
here
[Music]
hello
we're out and about
emma's in the back yeah
we are going to
small world finally i'll be huge oh mama
you know some people would think it's
hot
i think we're in the arctic or something
what has happened
we're trying to figure out parking
[Music]
why's there press the button
oh he's peeing he's peeing
only in japan everyone the tiniest key
i've ever seen
what's with the baby
this looks like one of the society memes
if everyone was up to pewdiepie or
something
[Music]
they're all watching sailor moon
this is supposed to be like a sailor
moon thing i don't really know how but
maybe it's it's this
there she is
[Music]
poor cow
it had to happen
how does this work oh it's like delayed
[Laughter]
this is tripping yeah
oh and just the two of you are in that
house oh yeah sorry emma you can't be
with us
[Music]
all the enemy babes drink milk coffee
guess i won't no thank you so you're
saving alien
that's actually
[Music]
can marzia be a dinosaur
[Music]
oh he's dead he's back alive
you gotta keep punching your jump punch
[Music]
oh my god one punch am i
punch that drug
damn
whoa
oh damn that truck got away
that's all i hated
[Music]
[Music]
if a dinosaur have a crunch between us
[Music]
[Music]
okay so it has been
two weeks
we've had
trash looking like this awful
because i ordered the wrong piece
so basically
japanese people don't have built-in
trash i'm a built-in trash kind of guy i
can't go without built-in trash i kept
thinking like okay so like where would
they put the trash
none of these drawers
make sense for trash to go in
and the only thing i can imagine is in
here and that's where we've been keeping
the trash but giant wasted space and the
fact that there is no flooring in it
makes it really difficult to find a
truck built in trash can that actually
fits i have found one the one and only
trash bin that is exactly the same size
as that cabinet i feel like this will be
really hard to install but if it works
i'm gonna be thrilled
[Music]
wait why is the
lid so small um
i ordered the wrong one
the new one orion if this doesn't fit
i'm gonna cry
if it's
yes
yes
oh what a relief this is so good we're
gonna have so much more space for trash
thank you germans i just gotta install
the door
it's not perfect but
i think that's as close to perfect as
i'm able to do it it was hard it was
really hard
i'm not gonna lie i'm very pleased
hey
you know my mom said
about the cable thing that i don't have
enough problems she also said that
it's good to care about stuff that other
people don't care about attention to
detail i think is what she's getting at
but yeah thank you germans
and japan you could learn something
about building trash come on
[Music]
we're just out and about looking around
finding cool stuff
so i know these
whites have told me about these so it's
called tanabata
and it's every year so people write
their wishes
on the colorful
paper and then they put it on bamboo
but it's so hot right now that uh
they're not doing too well
it's such a pretty road it goes all the
way
so cool